OF THE LAST FIVE.
DAVIS PUTTING ON ANOTHER
MAGNIFICENT PERFORMANCE WITH HIS
34 AND KEEPING THE LAKERS WITHIN
EIGHT.
WASHINGTON INBOUNDS.
AYTON.
WOW, TOOK ON THE SLEDGE HAMMER.
HE'S TAKING IT PERSONALLY.
>> Reggie: IF I'M A.D., I HAVE
TO GO RIGHT BACK AT THEM.
GIVE ME THE BALL.
>> Kevin: REEVES AGAINST UP
AGAINST BOOKER.
BOOKER KNOCKED IT AWAY.
REEVES IS DOWN.
>> Reggie: OH!
OH!
WHOA!
>> Kevin: AND THEY HAD WORDS
EARLIER.
>> Reggie: HE STRAIGHT LEVELLED
DEANDRE AYTON.
AND HE -- BEVERLEY IS UPSET
BECAUSE THE OFFICIALS WOULD NOT
CALL WHEN DEANDRE AYTON WAS
STANDING OVER AUSTIN REEVES.
AND HE TOOK OFFENSE TO THAT
BECAUSE THEY WOULDN'T CALL IT,
SO HE TOOK MATTERS INTO HIS OWN
HANDS.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN AN
IMMEDIATE TAUNTING FOUL BY DEAN
-- DEANDRE AYTON WHEN HE WAS
STANDING OVER REEVES.
WATCH THE WHOLE PLAY HERE.
HERE'S THE BLOCKED SHOT BY DEVIN
BOOKER.
SO THAT WASN'T A FOUL.
WOW!
>> OFFICIALS HAVE USED REPLAY TO
DETERMINE IF THERE WAS A
PHYSICAL ALTERCATION AFTER THE
FOUL.
>> Reggie: WELL, THERE CERTAINLY
WAS A HOSTILE ACT.
OH, MAN!
THAT IS A STRAIGHT BODY-CHECK
THERE BY BEVERLEY TO AYTON.
NOW CERTAINLY BEVERLEY IS GOING
TO BE GONE.
THERE IS NO EXCUSE FOR THAT.
I WILL SAY THAT.
BUT WHY HE DID THAT IS BECAUSE
HE WAS STANDING OVER AUSTIN
REEVES, HAVING WORDS WITH HIM.
>> Kevin: A PERSONAL FOUL WAS
CALLED ON BOOKER.
WHEN REEVES WENT DOWN, THEY DID
CALL A FOUL ON BOOKER.
>> Reggie: OH, MY GOODNESS.
NOW, THIS HAPPENED EVEN BEFORE.
BEFORE THIS PLAY HAPPENED ON THE
OTHER END, WHEN DEANDRE AYTON
HAD THE JAM AND HE WAS TALKING
NOISE TO ANTHONY DAVIS.
>> Kevin: AND THEN HE AND
BEVERLEY WERE JAWING.
>> Reggie: AND THE PLAY THAT
CAME DOWN WAS THIS PLAY RIGHT
HERE.
SO THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR A
WHILE.
LOOK AT THIS.
THERE IS A LOT TO SORT OUT HERE.
WELL, YOU COVER FOOTBALL A LOT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> Kevin: WELL, IN THE NFL THAT
WOULD BE HITTING A DEFENSELESS
RECEIVER.
>> Reggie: YES, IT WOULD.
>> Kevin: BUT I THINK WHAT YOU
SAID HAS MERIT IN THAT AYTON WAS
STANDING OVER A FALLEN PLAYER
AND LEAVING IN A TIMELY WAY AND
BEVERLEY TOOK EXCEPTION TO IT.
>> Reggie: YEAH.
PATRICK BEVERLEY ALREADY KNOWS
HE'S GOING TO GET THROWN OUT, SO
HE'S WALKING BACK TO THE LOCKER
ROOM NOW.
>> Kevin: HE WANTS TO GET A GOOD
SEAT ON THAT FLIGHT.
THAT WILL BE MORE THAN JUST AN
EJECTION.
>> Reggie: I AGREE.
THERE IS A SUSPENSION BEHIND
THAT.
SO HERE'S THE REPLAY.
SEE, I THINK THIS IS WHAT THE
OFFICIALS ARE LOOKING AT AS
WELL.
RIGHT HERE, THE TAUNTING BY
DEANDRE AYTON OVER REEVES.
THAT MIGHT BE A TECHNICAL FOUL
ON DEANDRE AYTON FOR THE
TAUNTING, WHICH LED TO BEVERLEY
BODY-CHECKING HIM.
OH, MAN.
THAT'S -- HEY, AM I MY BROTHER'S
KEEPER.
>> UPON REVIEW, THE FOUL
ASSESSED TO DEVIN BOOKER IS A
FLAGRANT FOUL.
WE HAVE DOUBLE TECHNICAL FOULS.
PATRICK BEVERLEY HAS BEEN
EJECTED FOR THE PHYSICAL FOUL.
AYTON ASSESSED A FOUL FOR HIS
TAUNT.
TWO S